hey guys it's tyro here with gamespot
and my fellow colleague dan huynh we are
here at e3 2015 and Dan you just saw a
game that I've been waiting for for a
long time Mirror's Edge catalyst I
didn't see it i play played it so I'm
one of those rare people that loved the
first Mirror's Edge floors and all I'm
right there with you I know it has
problems but I played the hell out of it
yeah so believe me when I tell you this
game is amazing catalyst fixes so much
of what was wrong with the original
Mirror's Edge and that's why when to
start it's been almost seven years since
the first one so run me through what has
been updated how does the gameplay feel
what they fix so the biggest problem
with the first game was combat you're
constantly getting shot at you're
getting frustrated cuz you don't know
where to go so the major change for this
one is that if you are moving at speed
bullets will never hit you okay so
you're encouraged to maintain your
momentum and when you are moving at
speed you've got two attacks one is
called a flow attack if you do this it
takes a guy down but you maintain your
momentum and you keep going okay you're
the ones called a transference attack
and that transfers your momentum to them
so it's about like kicking them off a
building or you know pushing them into
another guy and you just kinda keep
flowin like you just go for it like bang
down bang down he keep moving so I I
hear a lot now that this is more like an
open-world glass city than before and it
did you get to experience any of that
while you're playing again so they are
purposefully not saying open world and I
asked them specifically about this
because they're like oh we think of it
as more of a free-roaming adventure okay
and they're going to talk about
structure later in the year okay but
what I think it means is it's not a big
open world it's going to be like
sections of an open world that you run
around in but I did get to run around a
free-roaming section okay I did feel
free roaming yeah one of my favorite
things to do in the in the first game
was are the time trials and stuff with
friends I loved actually going up and my
friends listen to scene like okay how
fast was their time there is still one
to this very day that I'm trying to beat
and I'm curious i did you get a chance
to talk to any developers if they're
going to have that again for for
catalyst so there are actually time
trials just in the open world just there
in the free section you can go and start
a Time Trial from a certain point in the
city and then you run to the other end
okay arm you still have the run a vision
so items
or in the environment turn red red but
what happens is you can set a waypoint
on the map and it will dynamically
generate run a vision through that way
ah sweet Maedel really cool okay so uh
the other thing I wanted to talk to you
about was a story we there they're not
really calling this reboot this this is
more like an origin story yeah they're
saying origin story quite exactly so do
you learn any details on like where
faith is from how she became a runner
her clan of friends etc you sought out
in some kind of a detention facility but
beyond that they didn't really talk
about it oh yeah what I did see a lot
more of was kind of the mood and tone of
the game it's much more futuristic and
much more cyberpunk you actually have
like an artificial implant in your eye
that comes up with a heads-up display
right and it's it's a pretty ugly heads
up display but you know I asked them
about that as well and they said it's
like Collins it's like hollow lens is
it's actually says augmented reality and
you heard it here for a solid interface
but look it doesn't appear all that
often and they've actually tied the run
a vision into the fiction through that
the run a vision is part of the like
augmented reality okay interesting okay
well um I guess it looks like februari
is a twenty-third 2016 can't come soon
enough obviously for all information on
Mirror's Edge catalyst and the rest of
news coming out of V 3 2015 keep it
locked here at gamespot com
you